TOM SALMON: Welcome
to our session.
This is a joint session between
Google Cloud and Refinitiv,
one of the leading providers
of financial market data.
This session is a
great case study
of how BigQuery brings the speed
and scale of cloud computing
to financial market data.
We hear from
customers, the headache
of managing an on
premise infrastructure
to provide fast access to
petabytes worth of data
is a significant challenge.
This is a case
study of how we work
with Refinitiv to deliver
analysis-ready financial data
at scale.
My name is Tom Salmon
and I've been with Google
for around three and
a half years in the UK
financial services business.
I've been working deeply with
Refinitiv for the last 18
months to help them take
advantage of Google Cloud
and bring advantage to
our mutual customers.
I'm going to hand
over now to Catalina.
CATALINA VAZQUEZ:
Thank you, Tom.
Great being here today.
My name is Catalina Vasquez.
I head up the historical
database inside Refinitiv.
We're constantly
looking at solving
some of the most difficult
problems our users face when
accessing new data sets as well
as onboarding new sources that
will be relevant for workflows
across the front, middle,
and back office.
We have been working
with Google Cloud
as they've provided a
unique opportunity to solve
one of the largest
challenges our customers face
when dealing with large amounts
of historical pricing data.
Refinitiv is one of the largest
providers of financial markets
data and infrastructure.
We serve over 40,000
institutions and approximately
operate in 190 countries.
We provide leading data and
insights, trading platforms,
and open data and
technology platforms
that connect the global
financial markets
community in different ways.
We help drive performance in
trading, investment management,
wealth management, regulatory
compliance, market data
management, and also
fighting financial crime.
Our tech history
offering sits at the core
of key workflows for quants,
data scientists, traders,
and compliance functions.
In this context, let's
pause for a second and open
up the conversation
with one of the largest
challenges our
customers face when it
comes to financial market data.
For every dollar spent
on financial market data,
a further eight are spent
in processing, storing,
and transforming that data
before it can be analyzed.
So wouldn't it be great if
we could help change this?
We saw a great opportunity to
work together with Google Cloud
to solve this problem.
From the very
beginning, we knew we
were dealing with a
data set that would
be petabytes worth of data.
So I'll take you down a
short stroll down memory lane
to understand exactly
what tech history is
and how the history of
tech history started.
On the left, you will see
that we're back in the year
1867, when the first stock
ticker was unveiled in New York
City.
This revolutionized
the stock market
by making prices available to
investors around the country.
Before that, stock
tickers were actually
traveling by mail or messenger.
After a number of iterations,
the celebrated Thomas Edison,
amongst a few other inventors,
patented an improved version
of the stock ticker.
It was, indeed, one of
the first inventions
he managed to monetize.
The stock ticker
was later replaced
by a computerized ticker
with electronic displays
back in the 1960s.
We now fast forward
to 1969, and we
can see that ticker tape is all
across the streets of Chicago.
People are welcoming Apollo 11
astronauts back in the city.
Ticker tape was,
therefore, not only just
used in financial
markets, but also
to celebrate important
milestones across the world.
And finally, our time machine
takes us to the year 1997,
to a pub in London.
While internet
access was booming,
there was growing
interest to look
at quantitative
analysis for trading,
as well as process automation
happening in the trading
workflows.
Algorithmic trading required
increasing volumes of data
to create and test
these strategies.
A group of academics
finds out that we
have been storing ticker
tapes in our vaults for years
and wanted to access this
archive of every stock market
transaction to
conduct some research,
looking at market
microstructure and behavior.
This is how tech
history was then born.
Refinitiv collects
the data, arriving
from markets and
sources around the world
in unstructured formats.
We normalize, standardize,
and enrich this content
to make it usable.
So you can distinguish between
a government bond and a spot
effects rate, despite the fact
that every market and data
source uses different
conventions,
and different methods,
and describing factors
like instrument codes,
timestamps, location,
or currency codes.
As an end user, you
can consume the data
set in one normalized
and structured format.
Refinitiv tech history carries
over 20 years of pricing data
from over 500 exchanges
and specialist data sets.
This archive grows daily,
at a significant rate.
It's over five
petabytes worth of data,
compressed and archived,
ready for you to consume.
This requires
significant resources,
both to ensure that
you can keep up
with the rate at which new
data points are generated,
but also to make
sure that you have
the right infrastructure
required to deal
with such large data volumes.
Think of the compute, the
storage, and the network
costs linked to
doing this in house.
So going back to our
initial problem statement.
For every dollar
spent in market data,
customers are spending
an additional eight,
without even getting the
data ready to be analyzed.
We saw in Google
Cloud, an opportunity
to tackle the largest challenge
for historical data, which
is actually the ETL process,
or, Extract, Transform,
and Load process.
Traditionally, this would be
the customer's responsibility,
which meant each customer has
to keep a copy of the data set
in-house and had to allocate
expensive resources to unlock
access to it.
With BigQuery, we
have the opportunity
to transform our offering
and move away from a download
service, to now being able to
offer a managed tech history
database, allowing our
end users to access
that single source of
truth, ready for query,
as and when you need it.
So we stopped moving
the data around
and provided access to the data
where the capability actually
is.
This drastically reduces
timelines to access the data,
reduces the complexity
in the process,
but also ensures that a
single source of truth
is accessible to unlock
the right opportunities
across financial services.
So would you rather have your
quants and data scientists
adding value to the business,
or cleaning, aggregating,
and waiting for data access?
The reality is that
most of the time
would traditionally be spent
on cleaning, processing,
and transforming the data.
But we can now shift
this 80-20 rule around.
We can ensure that the
business gets what they want.
We can maximize the time
that data scientists, quants,
and end users spend on
adding value to the business
by providing timely access
to the data they need,
where they use it to run
machine learning models at scale
or build and backtest
new trading strategies.
We're already
seeing our customers
very happy about this.
We're able to enable
new workflows and also
new businesses to succeed.
We're allowing them
to focus on what
truly allows them to
differentiate in a highly
competitive environment.
So a single source of truth
that tech history provides
is used across the
full trading lifecycle.
It enables a more
efficient allocation
of resources across
the organization,
from preventing quants
and data scientists
from sitting idle,
waiting for data access,
to unnecessary
infrastructure spend.
From the pre-trade activities
that quants and data scientists
would perform for alpha seeking,
such as designing and back
testing new trading strategies,
to the at and post trade
analysis that would look to
reduce slippage or recreate
order book analysis.
And then finally, to
fulfilling compliance
and regulatory requirements
around transaction
cost analysis or algo
conformance testing.
One of the areas where we
find significant interest
in leveraging tech
history and BigQuery,
is within the quant and
data scientist community.
Tom is now going to cover
in a bit more detail, how
we can enable focus
on alpha generation,
rather than managing
IT infrastructure.
So Tom, over to you.
TOM SALMON: So I'd like
to dig a little bit deeper
into the life of a quant
using Google Cloud.
I use quant here interchangeably
for data scientists,
data engineers, and
even traders that code.
Really, it's anyone that wants
to get insight from data.
So I've broken this down
into four different pillars.
We have collecting
and transforming data,
finding patterns, training
models, and then deploying
those models.
Collecting and
transforming that data
has three different categories.
The streaming data,
which might be
up to the second,
real time stock market
data that's coming in.
You might collect that
through services like Pub/Sub.
You might be collecting
it and transforming
it using data flowing.
You could also stream it
directly into BigQuery as well.
BigQuery, here we're talking
around BigQuery for storage,
designed for exabytes
worth of storage,
which we'll talk about
in more detail later on.
In this example,
Refinitiv tech history
is loaded and immediately
available for querying
in BigQuery.
To complement this, firms
will bring their own data.
Position data, historical
trading data, and maybe
other data sets that they
have available to them
or that they've curated
and generated in-house.
Where there isn't a
structure to data,
we consider that
alternative data.
You'd load that into
Google Cloud Storage,
which is an object storage.
And from here,
typically, you want
to find patterns and
quantize that data.
They would use Google
Cloud's ML services,
for example, the natural
language processing API.
You can give it a PDF
document and extract
the key terms, and phrases,
and numbers from that document.
You could also take
an image and process
that image to understand
the contents of it
and to understand what
it's actually looking at.
Once you have these different
data sets that are stored
and you've done
the transformation
that you need to
make it available,
we then move to the analysis
phase to find those patterns.
So I've outlined three key
tools that people typically use.
At the top, we have Looker.
Looker is our
visualization platform
for looking at very
large amounts of data
and finding interesting
patterns through charts.
People might build
services like heat maps.
They might be using this
for time series data
to understand the relationship
between different data sets.
To get deeper, you'll be moving
into BigQuery for the analysis
phase, writing secret queries
for advanced analytics.
Alongside this, you can also
build machine learning models
directly inside BigQuery.
BigQuery ML extends SQL syntax
with an ML specific syntax,
allowing you to train
models directly in BigQuery,
taking advantage of
it's architecture, which
I'll explain more
deeply in future slides.
Thirdly, we then have users
that want to write code,
data scientists that want
to use Jupyter notebooks
or people that want to write
TensorFlow models directly.
They can spin up Jupyter
notebooks using Cloud AI Hub.
And then Cloud AI Hub has direct
connections and connectivity
into BigQuery, into
Google Cloud Storage.
The key is, this is a platform
that's horizontally integrated.
You're not having to deal with
networking and connectivity
and firewall rules.
All services have native
connectivity to each other.
So now we've found some
interesting pattern
or hypothesis.
We want to go and train
a model and backtest
and validate what it looks like.
So we'll then be moving
to our third pillar, which
is training models.
So training those
models, underlying it
needs a large amount of compute.
And we have different
flavors available.
For CPUs, you can access Intel
Skylake CPUs and Cascade Lake.
And even newer variants are
always coming available.
And these are in global data
centers around the world.
For machine learning
workloads, commonly, people
will use GPUs, Graphical
Processing Units, because they
significantly increase
the power available
and reduce the training time
for machine learning models.
Totally unique to Google,
we have a third level
called TPUs, Tensor
Processing Units,
which I've pictured here.
TPUs were designed
and built by Google
using custom silicon for our
precise needs for machine
learning.
To improve the accuracy
of Google search results,
to write better recommendations
for YouTube videos,
we needed to significantly
increase, through a step
change, the price performance
and power performance,
beyond GPUs, to a new level.
TPUs gave us that ability.
And you can rent,
effectively, some
of the most powerful
supercomputers in the world
by accessing TPUs.
So now you've
trained your model.
You've done your back
testing and your validation.
You then need to deploy
it to make it useful.
Cloud ML Engine allows you to
take the models that you've
trained through HPC computing--
You might have trained
them with TPUs.
them inside BigQuery.
You can then turn
them into an API.
You can turn it into
a RESTful endpoint.
And it also has
built-in batch features,
so you can run batch
predictions against data
that's in BigQuery or
inside Google Cloud Storage.
And now we're going to go
a bit deeper into BigQuery
to tell you about the
advantages of why BigQuery
is the best platform for this.
I'm going to focus slightly
deeper into BigQuery
now because I feel it's
really important to underline
the capabilities and
what makes it different.
The key headline for
BigQuery is, focus on insight
not infrastructure.
Google realized over the
years, that when analysts
have to think about the
size of the data warehouse
and the amount of
capacity, they end up
writing queries limited
by the infrastructure,
not limited by
their imagination.
So what we do, and the key
innovation of BigQuery,
is it's a serverless platform.
Google takes care of the
scaling, the operations,
and the resiliency.
It's a platform that you can
load in exabytes worth of data
and run petabyte-scale queries
over hundreds of trillions
of rows, and we automatically
scale it and manage it
on your behalf.
This means that when
your quants want
to find interesting
patterns, they
don't have to make trade-offs
as to how much compute
is available and
how many servers
are being used right now.
A key problem that we
hear from customers
is, the team in London
is OK during the morning,
but then it comes to lunchtime
and the New York team
come online, and suddenly
they get more competitive
towards the data warehouse.
There's a fixed number of calls
or a fixed amount of disk.
And then San Francisco comes
online and then further
countries.
And suddenly there's too
many [INAUDIBLE] people,
computing for too few
resources, and you end up
with contention and
everything slows down.
And then you revert
back to the focus,
is writing queries that
fit the infrastructure,
not queries that add
value to your business.
Underlying all of this, is
the architectural difference
around BigQuery.
We released a white
paper on the technology
we call Dremel, inside Google,
that we developed 10 years ago.
There's two key
components of Dremel.
On the left-hand
side is storage.
Replicated, distributed storage
with 11 nines of durability.
We can store exabytes of data.
100% of that is hot, online,
active, and queryable.
It has the same latency
profile, whether you're
querying data for an hour
ago, or 15 years ago.
It's immediately
available for querying.
The right-hand side is a highly
available compute cluster
that we manage on
behalf of our customers.
We make available a very
large amount of compute
in multiple data centers
around the world that
can be span up, on demand,
for each particular query
that comes in.
In the middle,
linking this together,
is a petabyte-scale
distributed memory tier.
Very customized, low
latency networking
to link these nodes together.
What happens here is,
when a query comes in,
we analyze that query to
work out the exact right size
and shape of data warehouse
needed for that specific query
at that specific time.
We know exactly
where the data is,
how we sliced it, sharded it,
partitioned it, and indexed it
on your behalf.
So we know how many
machines we might need
to read that data in parallel.
So we'll take a guess.
Maybe it's 100 or
1,000 to read the data.
Then we'll go through
the different phases
in the query lifecycle,
doing grouping, aggregation,
and filtering, and
more dynamically change
the size of that
cluster for you to use
the right amount of resources
to return the query as
quickly as possible.
So this is automatic and this
is managed on your behalf.
And every single user
for every single query
gets the experience
as if a data warehouse
had been custom built for that
exact query every single time.
And we spin this up
virtually on the fly for you.
I'd like to talk briefly around
the shared responsibility
model, where Google
Cloud provides
a benefit to Refinitiv,
who provides a benefit
to our mutual customers.
Google Cloud is externalizing
the infrastructure and data
centers that Google has spent
billions of dollars building.
We build and design our
own physical data centers.
own physical servers
and networking.
And this is public and
available in some great research
out there for you to look into.
We take care of managing
the physical infrastructure
on your behalf.
And typically, we
see organizations
having two choices.
They can consume
infrastructure as a service,
where they have access to
virtual machines in Google
Cloud.
They could take a third
party data warehouse platform
and they could spin
it up themselves.
But the first question,
they need to ask
is, how much storage do I
make available for my users?
How much RAM and compute
do I provide for my users?
And ultimately, you end
up making a trade-off.
Do you build a very
large data warehouse
and size it for peak capacity
but end up running it
when users aren't
accessing it, or do you
make it too small,
such that there's
too much contention and user
fighting over a finite number
of resources?
The difference with BigQuery
is, we manage that for you.
BigQuery is a
serverless platform
where we run the software,
the infrastructure,
and the networking.
We deal with the updates, the
operations, and the backup,
and everything to
ensure it's highly
performant for every user.
Refinitiv have three core
areas of responsibility.
Data design, that is,
designing the tables
and the layout of the data
that users interact with.
Data management, getting
the data into BigQuery,
ensuring it's up to
date, and making sure
that it goes through the
proper data lifecycle.
And then finally, access
control, sharing the right data
with the right end users.
The final piece is customers.
Their responsibility
is analyzing that data,
getting the value that is their
job to extract from that data.
So they don't have to
think about networking,
and cores, and storage
in the ETL process.
They focus on doing their job.
I'm going to hand back to
Catalina now to wrap us up.
CATALINA VAZQUEZ: Thanks, Tom.
So as we've seen today,
it is possible to access
query ready data,
without the need
to store or manage a real time
market data feed yourself.
You could also leverage BigQuery
compute and Google Cloud
tools to analyze
the data and not
have to worry about
provisioning storage or compute.
And finally, you can also
ensure that you have access
to an up-to-date, backed up,
and replicated data source,
without the need for you
to manage those backups
or disaster recovery instances.
It's not just a matter of
reducing the additional $8 that
are spent on processing,
storing, and transforming
the data, but it's also
about reducing the time
it takes to enable end users
across your organization
to access the relevant data
sets and allow them to focus
on where they can really make
a difference to your business,
whether that be the success
of the trading strategy,
managing risk more effectively,
or reducing costs of execution.
So hope you enjoyed the session
today and from both of us,
thanks very much for tuning in.